Nicholas sturgeon's resignation has
created pretty well total turmoil within
the SNP for a range of reasons which I'm
sure we can discuss but isn't it the
ultimate irony that one of the first
casualties of her the turmoil created by
her resignation and there she is is the
man standing next to her who is her
husband Peter mull the chief executive
of the snb's been the chief executive of
the party for 20 years he we continued
to be so well she was first Minister and
leader of the party and it's that fact
that conjunction of those two posts that
has for quite some time fomented
disquiet among a sector of the party I
stress only a sector small but
determined who believe that the SNP or
argue that the SNP has been run by a
cabal rather than being open to
democratic decision-making so they've
long been gunning for Peter model and
again the ultimate irony is that that
they bring him down just as Nicola
sturgeon is leaving now it's said to be
the model was would have stepped down in
any case once the new leader was in
place but he's had to go in a rather
undignified fashion yeah and Brian you
call it undignified it's worth just
reminding our viewers exactly how this
came about because it was when I read it
it's kind of a bit of back and forth and
a bit of confusion and a mistake that's
been made in counting of numbers and it
just ended up as you say being the the
end of it for for Mr Murrell I mean the
the membership of the SNP sawed after
the 2014 referendum result you remember
Scotland didn't vote Yes it was no by a
majority of 55 to to 45 but that there
seemed to be a feeling among members of
the public that they would Row in behind
the SNP almost as a compensation so
membership sought about 125 000 it was
down to about 104 000 by the end of 2021
um the party declined to disclose the
membership that would be taking part in
the the current leadership election I
understand why they didn't want it to be
an issue and they also didn't want to
confess that it's down to about 72 1000
a figure that other parties in Scotland
can only dream of but for the SNP is
well down from those Peaks Peter model
made a fundamental mistake in in when
the when he was challenged about those
figures he he obfuscated he dodged he
went he got he got around the subject he
said he was answering questions about
the source of the decline rather than
the numbers basically he didn't put
forward the straightforward numbers to
me if you're going to lead in a
democracy you mustn't mislead because
eventually you're going to be found out
and that was the case here he says he
doesn't he doesn't feel that he there
was intentional misleading but he Bears
responsibility and so he's gone but you
must understand that is that that wider
sense of of criticism of of what they
believe is a cabal about you know it's
it's two or three MPS some other members
it would appear that Ash Regan one of
the candidates is now rowing is is
heading towards
um that sector of opinion within the
party now those uh who support us
actually in there those who support
um the the position adopted by Nicola
sturgeon say that the critics are Rebels
without a clue that they are putting
forward arguments and putting forward
complaints without having a strategy
other than just replacing the leadership
and replacing the chief executive what's
happened in the party is that Mike
Russell the party president the former
cabinet minister very senior figure
indeed a former Chief Executive himself
in fact predecessor of Peter model has
taken over the the day-to-day running of
the party on a voluntary unpaid basis
until a new leader is in place and a new
chief executive is in place this is one
guttle it's one Burke to use a Scots
phrase for the the SNP can they get out
of it yes they can if the new leader can
settle things down there is an
incredible impetus within the SNP to
gather around to unify why because
they're not simply a party they are also
a movement but it's going to take some
effort to achieve it on this occasion
now it certainly doesn't appreciate that
phrase sugary Peg was also one that I
was told about uh when it came to um a
while ago Brian tell them appreciate
that thank you very much for your time